what up cisgendered [ __ ] today's topic
this is a story that happened here in
Montreal a white dreaded comedian was
refused access to a comedy show because
of the fact that he was white while
having Tourette's the place that refused
him access is called the coop link court
well the only thing they've been able to
harvest is a lot of hate
so after all this negative feedback that
they received for refusing this comedian
they put out a statement it says the
coop neither cut is a safe space free
from oppression we refused a white
person wearing dreads to perform as part
of our to comedy nights snowflake comedy
club [ __ ] performance for his move
generati
manifests for his move except in a
snake's eye comedy club proud of their
idiots or they're just really trying to
live up to their name you're making this
[ __ ] up but I appreciate the commitment
cultural appropriation is the fact that
person from a dominant culture
appropriate symbols clothes or
hairstyles of people from historically
dominated culture so from your
perspective you feel like a white man
wearing dreadlocks is appropriately
something from a different culture when
in reality the oldest records of
dreadlocks known to man come from
ancient Egypt in ancient Greece which
again had a lot of white people so his
idea that dreadlocks belonged to black
people historically is not accurate you
cannot claim something that is for black
culture and that belongs to black people
just because black you wouldn't
predominantly have it today it'd be like
saying hip-hop is for white people
because white people are all the people
that attend hip-hop concerts we live in
a society where systemic racism is
present and we're spaces where
racialized and marginalized people can
feel very safe are rare fare ku crops
aspires you mean the Christian
[Music]
it's like co-op did he cut but we're not
puttin translate as a black person as a
minority I don't like safe spaces always
be wary of these places that claim to be
inclusive or safe spaces places that
promote these ideas are the most
homogeneous gathering of 1% white milk
you can find on the planet you walk in
and it's straight wonder brain
everywhere you look
you know I don't mind homogeneity in a
crowd I'm fine with it just being white
before whatever provided there is
diversity in thought the groupthink and
these places has gone to such an extreme
that the very people for whom they claim
to put these events on four do not
attend their event we want diversity
does not diversity in opinion then you
don't have diversity
you are a uniform fragile glass
masquerading as a mosaic what the [ __ ]
you're a fraud you are not for real okay
call me black ice black axe yeah cuz you
never see me coming smash my shoe is
more so with white people having this
white Savior complex where these
liberals will come out and think that
they're doing mine or either service by
speaking on our behalf when actually
they're speaking on a minority amongst
minorities most black people look at
this and like y'all are ridiculous we
don't care about what you're doing so
who are you really fighting for yourself
you don't realize it but in your fight
for inclusivity you have become
exclusive they like to pat themselves on
the back like I'm such a good person no
and you're using art our struggle and
our issues to further your own personal
agenda so you can feel like you're a
great person butchered oh shut up a
black man that must be for you all right
cool yeah you cannot because these black
people suffer they see look look that's
the face of suffering he suffers he shut
up he suffers we want diversity we just
don't want diverse
opinions you're not diverse may not it's
a diverse light if the diverse goes in
free it's a diverse zero it's a diverse
no trans fat no what's funny though is
that with this you want to be
progressive the only thing you're
allowed to laugh at is right
ether no sexual man that's not
progressive this is why I do not like
the idea of safe spaces it's a breeding
ground for wolves and sheep's clothing
people who like to prey on the
vulnerable go to these safe spaces
because everyone's defenses are down and
what happens afropunk oh yeah
oh yeah people were putting on afropunk
afropunk i was suspicious off the top
your safe space ain't so safe anymore
no no who's coming for you the Ku Klux
Klan they got pulled by afro okay right
in addition we are certain that you will
understand that it is unacceptable to
compare the fact of denying a person a
platform of a few square meters to the
systemic oppression experienced by
marginalized people you are wrong for
what you did doesn't mean that you are
as wrong as the people who created you
crow it just means that you're wrong so
don't try to deviate from that fact okay
you cannot fight from marginalized
people by marginalizing others I'm not
gonna deny the fact that black people
wearing dreads and their white people
dress there's a different connotation
you don't bring people up by bringing
people down you don't say yeah you might
be evening it but you just made everyone
social situations worse it's not by
making other people suffer the way I
suffered
that we're gonna get along I'm just
causing them pain how is that a good
thing it got to me after my wait a
minute I think you're just well you know
there's a prison and isn't that okay I
understand you're trying to be an online
I cook cool that that's art but that
wait Oh relax Tim Wise that's not how
you that's not how you do it a safe
space it's gonna ban a queer guy with
dreads from performing that's
cannibalism are going at each other what
the [ __ ] can y'all sit down and talk
thought about we don't serve you can
around here so you didn't bother you so
much they were speaking on your behalf I
would that wasn't not the first thing I
bothered I was like wow you Yoli blossom
human I'm curious you know what are your
solutions to decisions you want them to
cut them off do you want them to pay a
tax just you know pay up for their
privilege look at this tweet any white
guy with dreads I think me it doesn't
matter anyone who doesn't like this is a
hundred white guy with dreads here's 100
percent a white guy with dreads so
anyone who disagrees with them is
immediately part of it if I disagree
with anything a feminist says then
therefore I'm a misogynist Pig right oh
my you're wrong if I disagree with
something that a black person says in
terms of racism that I'm part of white
supremacy if I disagree with the fact
that a white person should get you
shouldn't get discriminated then I'm
therefore a white guy with dreads like
if these kind of reductionist things
that people say that limit our ability
to have a conversation talk these ideas
through
[Music]
Hey destruction of private property yes
a lot he gets raped by somebody and
they're like I can a 16 year old and I
can't have this baby I think you should
keep it
it's a baby if someone is raped and she
gave birth and she decided to kill her
three-year-old child
[Applause]
[Music]